hey Vsauce Michael here if we turned the
moon into a giant disco ball
day and night would not be a disco party
instead of diffusely reflecting sunlight
onto all of us a mirror tiled moon would
reflect specularly you would be lucky to
momentarily catch a single reflected
beam of sunlight now with the help of
visuals by Nick from Yeti dynamics who
you should subscribe to immediately
let's see what would occur if a disco
ball moon actually happened here's the
earth with an imaginary screen behind it
so we can track the path of reflections
from a disco ball moon it's 3012 mirror
tiles are ten kilometres thick in
between 100 and 150 kilometers across
and as you can see the beams of sunlight
they reflect would only intersect with
earth briefly and rarely a few every
month or so would race past at more than
20,000 kilometers a second from the
surface of Earth they'd just be tiny
flashes in the sky the 0.1% as bright as
the regular Sun and would last a
fraction of a second the Earth's Sun and
Moon just aren't in ideal locations for
disco ball effects but if our disco ball
moon was closer and orbited earth not
384,000 kilometers away but less than
450 as far as the International Space
Station does it would be torn apart by
gravitational tidal forces shoot also
the moon doesn't really rotate from our
perspective like a fun disco ball it ly
breaks but it's starting to look like
instead of an awesome lunar party
decoration a disco ball moon would just
be a lunar party pooper so for the sake
of investigation let's allow this disco
ball moon to not be torn apart and allow
it to spin in the sky now we're talking
occasionally we would get glittery
reflections of a dimmer
image of the Sun from the surface of
Earth this is what we would see
[Music]
you know being able to see earth
reflected is almost cooler it's like
being a bacterium on a giant space who's
looking into a mirror you can see the
giant but not yourself it kind of makes
you feel small but it would be a great
way to take planetary selfies so let's
watch a mirror the width of the moon
orbit as close as the ISS does from the
surface of Earth it would look like this
the strobe lights around the edge by the
way are ten kilometers across
[Music]
pretty cool now finally let's take a
look at the moon as a rotating disco
ball from low orbit
[Music]
the moon is not a disco ball and likely
never will be it's just a diffuse source
of illumination but it's illuminating in
a different way to imagine what would
occur if it actually happened whoa and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]